Well,
I think one of the key lessons or
reminders is how intertwined main street
and Wall Street really is.
When we were,
uh,
working with the federal government,
um,
during the Aig crisis,
one of my biggest concerns and that very
rapid collapse of aig was how many
companies in this country could have
liquidity choked out and they didn't,
they,
it,
it was coming too quickly and the
implications across the country were
profound.
And so I think one,
recognizing how important it is to,
um,
have a,
a safe yet robust financial system if we
hope to have financial growth is a very
important,
um,
uh,
reminder.
And that in fact,
if you don't have a healthy financial
system,
it's hard to,
to fund the growth that small,
medium,
large companies and individuals need and
deserve.
So I think,
again,
it's the relationship between main
street and Wall Street is important.
Curbing excesses is clearly important
and I think putting us on a stable base
so we can have that consistent growth in
the industry to support capitalism.
Otherwise,
again,
um,
we can't have the growth that,
that the country needs to do.
You can have the growth economy needs.
I'm generally an optimist.
I think I've seen so many cycles in my
23 years in the business.
I started in August of 1987 only to see
the market have one of the biggest
crashes ever in October of 87.
And seeing a number of other cycles and
after each one,
lessons or lessons are learned.
And I think that the pendulum often
swings too far one way before it comes
back the other way.
But there's a,
an important learning and growth
opportunity that comes out of,
um,
each one of these situations.
This is clearly more profound than what
we've seen in many,
many decades.
And so one would hope that we're
building the right foundation to grow
from the space.